Should I be taking methylcobolamine B12 as a cancer patient?
In general, no, you shouldn't.
So methylcobolamine is a form of B12.
So remember, the main forms of B12 out there are
the inorganic form called cyanocobolamine,
which is not good and I don't recommend for anybody.
Then you got hydroxylcobolamine
and adenosylcobolamine, which don't have methyl groups.
Or it's bound to a methyl group and it's called methylcobolamine.
So these are all forms of B12.
Well, I heard that people should be taking methylcobolamine
because that helps with the MTHF or gene defect.
Well, yeah, it can help with the MTHF or gene defect.
But if you have cancer,
methyl groups can silence tumor spressor genes
so they can block the intrinsic apoptonic pathway,
meaning that inside the cell,
you have a pathway stimulated by what are called tumor suppressor genes
that will stimulate cell death when a cancer,
when a cell is going to rapid replication.
AKA is being cancerous.
So when you got a cell that's acting as its cancer,
meaning it's rapidly replicating,
your tumor suppressor gene should kick it and kill the cell.
Well, methyl groups block that,
methyl groups attached to that gene and turn that gene off.
So it allows for the cancer to continue to grow.
So cancer patients should not be taking methylfolate.
You'll see that a label is methyl-tenterhydrofolate
or methylfolate,
or they should not be taking methylcobolamine.
The only exception to that is if a person has a blood test,
elevated homocysteine.
So if a person has normal homocysteine levels
and they have a diagnosis of cancer,
they should not be taking excess methyl groups.
If they have, well, what if they have an MTHFR defect?
It doesn't make any difference.
If you have cancer and you have a normal homocysteine,
you should not be taking methylfolate,
nor should you be taking methylcobolamine.
Well, then they're not detoxified because the MTHFR gene
has got defects on it.
No, no.
So does the MTHFR gene help with detoxification?
Yes.
There's a lot of other detox pathways.
Taking excess methyl groups are going to silence genes.
They're also going to do other things, too.
So you never just recommend any practitioners are listening.
You never just recommend methyl groups
because the person has an MTHFR gene defect.
You have to look at all the genes.
If you have an MTHFR gene defect,
and they're bioptored pathway,
you're going to strongly push that pathway as well.
You could have all sorts of mood issues as well.
Only caveat to that is if a person has excess homocysteine,
then we're going to have to take methyl groups for a short period of time.